ja und sie hat die masken pflicht
eingeführt doch irgendwie haben wir die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel noch nicht
wirklich mit maske gesehen das hat auch
einige unserer kollegen in letzter zeit
irritiert warum sieht man frau merkel
eigentlich nie mit maske auffällig ist
aber dass man sie selbst noch nie mit
einer maske gesehen hat woran liegt das
ja wenn ich die abstandsregeln einhalte
brauche ich die maske aufzusetzen und
wenn ich sie nicht einhalte und ich zum
beispiel einkaufen gehe dann treffen wir
uns nicht offensichtlich sonst hätten
sie mich auch schon mit mars gesehen
können verraten aber nicht war nicht wo
einkaufen gehen
es wird auch andere gelegenheiten geben
wo ich sicherlich noch mit maske zu
sehen sein werde ich ja gesagt getan
heute war es dann soweit ja die
kanzlerin vorbildlich wie wir hier
gerade sehen mit mundschutz vor ihrer
rede zur eu-ratspräsidentschaft und als
sie dann den platz einnimmt auf der
regierungsbank nehmt ihr die maske
wieder ab die schüler dort haben nämlich
ein abstand von ein meter fünfzig
zueinander